dans cette crèche à montlouis le premier
réflexe pour les petits quand ils
arrivent le matin c'est d'utiliser cette
rapaces avons une rotation de manivelle
et le tour est joué plus besoin de tous
ces bidons en plastique
ils ont été remplacés par du savon
solide une démarche écologique que l'on
retrouve aussi dans les activités des
enfants ici le sable magique a été
fabriquée maison avec de la farine de
l'huile et de la craie pour la couleur
mais la démonstration ne s'arrête pas là
une fois l'activité finie elle les
tables sont nettoyés sans aucun produit
chimique mais avec de l'eau aux zones et
cette machine que je vais vulgairement
appelée à nos donateurs permet à partir
de l'eau de robinet d'avoir une eau
chargée en ion et qui permet à un
nettoyage très efficace de toutes les
surfaces et des sols donc même des jeux
des jouets aussi efficace qu un
détergent désinfectant hautement
puissant qu'on pouvait utiliser jusqu'à
présent à l'heure du repas aussi les
changements sont visibles la vaisselle
en plastique a disparu et les bacs en
inox réutilisables ont supplanté les
barquettes jetables dans les assiettes
50% des aliments sont issus de la
filière biologique des engagements qui
ont permis à la structure de décrocher
le label écolo crèche en juin 2021
oui on est en avance il ya à peu près de
12000 structure en france et n a que six
ans labellisé falla et dans l'indre et
loire je pense que nous sommes la seule
structure publique à être labellisé donc
évidemment que ça je peux que évoluer
plus avancé ce label c'est aussi un gage
de sérieux pour les parents qui laissent
leurs enfants gardent ici au quotidien
les petits intègre naturellement ces
pratiques plus respectueuses de
l'environnement
alors attention à l'environnement
réutiliser les affaires à ne pas
systématiquement jeter et c'est
vachement que c'est vraiment bien et
important ça nous montre aussi dès le
départ
ddd bons gestes à voir au quotidien
qu'ils voient appliquer dans tout ce qui
est équipements et tout ce qui est
vêtements et produits
donc tout ça c'est plutôt rassurant pour
nous pour les parents ce label est
valable trois ans il est aussi le témoin
de l'engagement de la structure et de
ses douze salariés car sans leur
participation
rien est évidemment possible